and a friend of the program in a guy who
I'm pleased to call a friend Scott Boras
back here on the Rich Eisen show I think
he represents how many people are Major
League Baseball 1 million people
immediately yeah roughly right around
there give or take a few Scott Boras
back here on the show how are you Scott
Irish I hope that you and Susie and the
family are all well we are and and safe
how about you everything good with you
and yours yes you know you talk to so
many people Becky's particularly in
Northeast and and those of us that are
out here the virus has really just
brought a different experience because
of for a lot of reasons so I'm you know
I think we're very fortunate and I'm
happy for them that things are
mitigating and and we're getting this
under control a bit yeah I'm knocking on
wood on that and obviously a return to
normalcy would would would would feel a
lot more comforting for a lot of people
with the return of sports and so I'm
wondering what can you tell us as we sit
here right now about you know what you
know about what baseball and its Players
Association is discussing about a return
action in 2020 Scott you know the you
know the players I represent and and the
Union they've they really been at the
forefront of you know working with MLB
because obviously this is not the fault
of anyone and you know I was really good
in March that you know right after
baseball shut down the two sides got
together and and really worked hard
rolled up their sleeves and put together
some parameters that certainly allowed I
think a platform and a foundation for
them to to put a focus together and and
allow baseball to to continue I think
the players made it you know made a
substantial the under the CBA there was
a 162 games they were owned about four
and a half billion dollars and salaries
and the players basically have taken a
substantial
sorry cut in sense that they didn't
obligate the the owners to offer those
hundred sixty two games and basically
said we're going to get paid on a
pro-rata basis going forward and so it's
you know that's that's something I think
that you know Tony Clark and the union
leadership and the players really got to
that point saying we're you know we're
going to work hard do to be a good
partner and compromising this thing to
go forward so that was back then and now
I guess the fact that there is going to
be no fans in the stands
according to baseball changes the
financial equation of whatever was
agreed to back in March and that appears
to be the issue that's at hand right now
am I correct in that assumption no I
think in March you know actually the the
virus was much worse and a much more
unknown than and I think it was very
clear and you know the parties kind of
having an agreement that there's you
know it games it to be played there's a
you know you have to economically it
have to be economically feasible and the
two sides would sit down and talk about
that feasibility and and certainly the
evidence to date is because the
television contracts and regional
national and then the postseason which
the owners actually have a kind of
bonanza because they don't share any of
those billion dollar type rights with
the players it's is that there is ample
economics to suggest it's very feasible
to play games without fans and and have
you know owners and such certainly have
a season where they're not going to make
the money that they did in a normal
dynamic neither will the players but
still continue with a productive
schedule so I'm trying to pick up what
you're putting down here Scott so if if
if baseball is in fact trying to
[Music]
term the March agreement as inoperative
based on the current virus boots
figuratively as you know on the ground
that that would be a non-starter I think
this is these are bridges already built
based upon the conditions that were far
worse then because of the unknowns I
mean again there's there's a direction
about economic feasibility the ties will
discuss whether or not they play games
but we've in the process of that there's
always just there was already an
agreement and discussion as to whatever
games they do play we know that the
payer the players will receive a pro
rata share of their salaries for doing
it so those are two separate issues
whether or not they play games or not or
what players are paid as its as to what
the parties you know agreed to back then
so I mean Scott Boras here on the Rich
Eisen show so fans are hearing at least
last week a 50-50 revenue split would be
what baseball is looking for and fans
hear that okay that's uh that's that's
fair you you're you're each taken half
and then players are saying or at least
Players Association saying that that's
not good at all
as a matter of fact it's something that
Blake Snell said he wasn't willing to
risk playing can you explain why the
players take that stance then Scott
well I my point is is that in fairness
to the parties that are negotiating this
the Union and Major League Baseball and
and certainly from the players I
represent this the the context of how
they work over the years is that we
don't have a salary cap we don't have we
have a bargaining history that is
completely different you know I I've
learned long ago that the definition of
revenue is something that is it's like
galaxies it's undefinable it you can't
really determine what revenue is because
there's so many ways to move that
needle around but essentially look
baseball and we have one public company
that we know because it file returns the
Atlanta Braves they they were purchased
you know 15 years ago for 450 million or
a million and now they're worth one
point eight billion their revenues in
2016 we're 260 May and now they're four
hundred and seventy five man
they're making a great deal of money and
and so in those instances you don't hear
anything about any form of radical
change about a change of our structure
and what we do without a salary cap and
going to revenue sharing but the point
is it was never ever requested or sought
for because they privatized the games so
you you can't privatize the games and
socialize socialize the losses and these
things you have a platform you do what
you do but in fairness to everybody this
concept I think came into the media rich
but I don't think there's any evidence I
think the parties are working as they
should work and I'm not involved in that
negotiation but I would certainly think
that you know we just need to give them
time to to work through what they're
going to work through before we make any
assessments but we have a very healthy
game the owners in baseball have nearly
tripled their values and their
franchises for those that have over
clubs over ten years and the game is
very very healthy we have obviously a
pandemic and a public health issue that
got in the way of this that really
affected the players and what their
earnings are and affects the owners and
what their earnings are and I'm sure
that the methods a [ __ ] with which they
deal are going to be more patterned
along the lines of the structures that
were in place prior to you know them
going into this negotiation Scott Boras
here on the Rich Eisen show and before
we do move into what what you you know
or what your your clients know about the
safety and the health issues and
baseball's protocols that they put
together I just want to spend one last
question on
the revenue side of things here because
again you obviously you don't you're not
in the negotiation as you pointed out
you don't you know you're not in the
Union but you do represent a large
number of players many of whom are very
famous and the ones who if they say
something would definitely move the
needle so that said I've you know
wondered about what's going on right now
and you've said many times about what
happened in March as if that isn't
negotiated this is settled this is a
settled issue in terms of revenue and it
seems like baseball is making a seem as
if it is not a settled issue and that is
the issue that I'm concerned about do
you think that that is something that
can be eventually settled so we can get
to baseball here Scott the parties
understand that there's an economic
feasibility that in good faith that
they're in discussion and I think to
date this is something that should not
be discussed publicly but they're going
to be talking privately about
demonstrating the the economic quotient
here are certainly our data because we
know the TV contracts and we know what
players are making for a partial season
is that it's if the the bottom line is
it's definitely without question more
beneficial for owners to play and have a
season and earn those media contracts
without fans than it is for them to not
play and suffer very serious losses by
not producing the game and rich remember
there are many players who have
guaranteed contracts going into the
twenty one season and well beyond you do
not want your athletes and the assets of
your franchise to not perform for a year
and then come back and play because you
don't want starting pitchers going from
where they were throwing maybe a hundred
and forty hundred and fifty innings and
then they platform into a couple hundred
innings in twenty one you don't want
them going from zero and not pitching
for over a year to then being asked to
throw 200 innings that would result in a
dramatic impact
on the potentials for injury and de
munition of skill so you've got a whole
element of this in my mind that prompts
if you're a franchise owner and
preserving the skills of you have your
development of your players the
preservation of your existing assets
that you definitely have very strong
reasons economically to say we need to
play baseball few more minutes left with
Scott Boras de Barras corporation here
on the Rich Eisen show I'm assuming
you've read the 60 plus page document
that baseball put together for health
protocols and I'm wondering what you
thought of it Scott do you think that
this is a doable well I think the what
we've done is is that with our clients
we've gotten doctors and you know we've
studied the therapeutics and as you know
rich I have a medical background and
studied pharmacology so we've we've done
a lot of educational work over the last
two months with our clients about what
the expert immunologists neurologists
Parral adjust have to say about this and
I think the players have a good
understanding because of their age group
and where they're at with you know
making an assessment of the safety but
the great thing is - we've got an
operational model in Korea and Taiwan
where people have been together and
playing for over ninety days there's not
been any hospitalizations and and
obviously the survival rate is a hundred
percent so we're really looking at all
of all that information and we will we
get health care professionals they're
going to give a very concerned and
professional opinion about what they
want players to follow and then on the
other side of it players have to look
into the fact of the functionality and
the needs of them performing their what
they do on the field and also what they
must do to prevent injury and so I think
you put you look at the both sides of
that and you take a close look you talk
about the profession the
needs to sustain performance and sustain
a career and you also talked about the
public health issue needs from those
professionals that I think you map it
out and I think that process is ongoing
okay last one for Scott the the the
$64,000 question proverbially or four
billion dollar question literally from
what we're hearing
brass tacks it for me I'm sure you get
this question all the time I'll just add
my name to that list do you think
there's baseball in 2020 well you know I
think because when you study medicine
you understand that the prohibitive
factor on this is the medical expert
opinion about the safety and care of the
process the people involved and everyone
and once you know that the medical
science and we're talking about now we
have vaccines that are going to be
coming hopefully a lot earlier the
therapeutics the testing was in advance
there's even new testing mechanisms on
the forefront that are more immediate
and accurate when you have all those
things evolved with the great medical
minds that's what's making me so
positive about the idea that we can
create an employment environment and a
game and put it on and continue and
frankly give America something that
really tells us we're back to normalcy I
think it's a big barometer for that and
so I'm in very encouraged about where we
are from with our understanding of the
virus from the medical community and
that's really what's given me a very
optimistic view about the return of
baseball Scott thanks for the time glad
to hear everybody's happy and healthy in
your neck of the woods let's let's keep
in touch always a pleasure rich right
back at you that Scott Boras right here
on the Rich Eisen show Scott Boras again
representing a hundred and seventy five
players in Major League Baseball and
actually a man who received his Doctor
of pharmacy degree from the university
of Pacific in 1977 say he wasn't joking
nope he wasn't joking
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here